first of all this dress is insane did
you design it and cute no I did not it's
not one of mine but I'm in love with it
and if I hit the light just right I
become my own disco ball you're so
fabulous everything about you you're so
good in this movie it's it's it's crazy
how you transform and I forget that it's
megastar Melissa McCarthy what is this
meant to you to be a part of this
particular kind of a sleeper that
everyone has discovered and fallen in
love with you know I just I fell in love
with Lea Israel right away I think I was
about page 15 and I just thought I'm not
sure why because she's tricky but I
loved her right away and I I think I
just went into it was such a love of her
and for Jack played so beautifully by
Richard II grant and I think everybody
felt the same about these two kind of
forgotten lonely people that they still
needed someone there was so of this like
lovely friendship and I don't know it's
just I mean I think today there's so
much harsh things going on in the world
that you just kind of need to reconnect
with like a story about real people and
humans and loneliness and there's an
element of imperfection we are all
imperfect and we all know that imperfect
person in our lives that we still love
and I felt like you really showed that
oh thank you about this Oscar nomination
you got an Oscar nomination
take it up taking it down start talking
what happened first I answered the phone
and I was like it is I thought it was
like my parents alarm going off so I was
like isn't the alarm it's like what's
the code and then somebody was like for
God's sakes you were nominated I'm like
is it a lot like I couldn't I couldn't
figure out what was happening and then I
immediately call I talked to Mary Heller
are brilliant awesome remarkable
director first and she said videos of
her screaming and stuff and then I
talked to Richard immediately and we
just we were both so overwhelmed by it I
mean there's there's no way to have that
happen and you know just think oh I'm
sure I'm dreaming but it's a pretty good
dream I want to be dreaming where's your
bag do you have a sandwich for me I
might have a sandwich and I did not
bring my duffle up sandwiches
which I didn't know was gonna become
such a thing but I'm your favorite
person of all 240 of them I gave that 40
so Richard earlier and I was like you
know listen I'm happy for you guys the
movies ahead Oscars but like do you have
a sandwich and she's I wondered if he
took a request before like bring me to
read you I did take a specific request
from him because he doesn't eat cheese
which I find real sketchy okay
people that don't you Richard II grant
does eat cheese and then Murray's a
vegan so I brought two specialty
sandwiches and then everybody else got
ham and cheese you promise to Instagram
or like post a photo tonight of the
sandwiches that was back okay but
there's no sandwiches I'm not gonna say
either way I did have one in my bag then
I took it then I been the ate it on the
way on the way here he ate my one
sandwich also the best congratulations
[Music]